[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
everything has an appointed season and
there's a time for every matter under
heaven a time to give birth a time to
die a time to plant and a time to
harvest what is planted but time to weep
and a time to laugh colleagues friends
family of the extraordinary visionary
galvanizing and remarkable Vincent Jay
Scully jr. welcome over the centuries
Yale has been lucky lucky to have its
rightful share of charismatic scholars
and teachers people who've moved
knowledge forward changed minds and
lives with their powerful teaching tales
of Benjamin Silliman holding his
chemistry classroom spellbound or of
John Pitkin Norton inspiring students
and the general public about the
practical value of applying scientific
methods to agriculture abound in Yale
history but I'm quite confident
confident that even among these there is
no single person in all of our over 317
years who did this as well or for as
long a time period as Vincent Scully and
so Vince may be unique in the annals of
Yale I'm not going to try to say much
about Vince now because many others here
will do that today instead I'm simply
going to say that the single word that
is appropriate for what he gave to Yale
is our gratitude we are grateful
for Vince once in a long while someone
like Vince comes along and we are
fortunate when that miracle the miracle
of Scully happens to us happens to us
here at Yale this afternoon we'll begin
with a short video clip of Vince himself
followed by speakers other video clips
and some music that will bring him back
to us and allow us surrounded by the
community of so many who loved him to
pay tribute to him one more time thank
you for being here
[Music]
that kind of synthesis of those things
that are in Corbusier and Otto dominated
all the time by this beautifully humane
sense of the receiving of the light of
every day now this house has had a
significant history now it's true that
which caught published it he praised it
for a very modern quality he said it has
almost no detail very spare and sparse
no decoration because he was still
seeing it as a modernist now this is the
building in his book that caught my eye
precisely for the same reason I was
prepared to see basically still in a
modernist way George Hamilton Yale who
was my advisor but be in touch for the
Henry Russell Hitchcock it was really
the dean of architectural historians at
that time and he was a very generous
adviser for me and my dissertation which
was on American 19th century
architecture and then I published a book
about that the shingle style in
post-world War two u.s. you'd see all of
these quote shingle style buildings but
you never knew that they were shingle
style or even architecture same we're
not in any books they were not talked
about in any way and systematically and
suddenly to have Scully present them if
the complex arguments that he developed
for them both spatially tectonic Lee
culturally linked to the literature the
politics of the day it was amazing
suddenly what were just buildings became
architecture 1939 it shows you how nice
it would be the buildings on both sides
you know you notice are conforming to
the spin of the road the buildings are
formed by that movement of those
automobiles the automobile is everything
doesn't matter watch you knock down if
you get from one place to another in two
minutes faster by knocking down a whole
street that's 100 years old you've got
to do it because that's reasonable to
get there faster
I paid no attention when Phillip Johnson
and John Lindsay bigoted should try to
save Pennsylvania station in 1963
[Music]
like most modernists at that time I just
didn't think it really saving anything
here because had to be new it's
ridiculous
when redevelopment our bure developed in
New Haven I began to see you couldn't
just stay in your ivory tower anymore no
I couldn't just be interested in the
Greek temples that I come back to my
hometown
[Music]
you
apparently arrow came out here and flew
balloons at various Heights he let some
go up and he pulls him down to try to
get the heights of the towers so the
height of every tower was arrived at
empirically and purely visually the
number of floors of rooms they have are
determined by the visual character of
its height then when Khan came along and
he was here before you were at Yale and
you never studied with him no but I did
my architecture on the top floor at
least the part that was good up there
was a great show that's fantastic and
this is the first building built when
he's in this early 50s and which he
tries to start again if you compare with
that one it too is very reductive it's
so little here compared to what's there
but there is a kind of splint there's a
kind of sense of a beginning he's really
starting here to try to understand what
a classical building in a town is this
is the first modern building Yale and to
my mind most moving
[Music]
the possible exception of the British
dart Center there are very few times in
the entire history of architecture where
an historian delves into an area of
architectural history studies it
interprets it puts it before the
audience including young architects this
was one of the rare times when an
architectural story and a profound
effect on architecture
[Music]
you
it is not quite true that architecture
was Vincent Scully's subject he taught
about it and wrote about it for more
than six decades and it is not possible
to imagine greater passion being brought
to it but his true life's work was
always something more something for
which the buildings in the cities that
are nominally his subject were but a
vehicle and that is the whole idea of
human community and culture if his work
contains any overriding message it is
that architecture is part of that larger
culture and that its meaning comes from
its connectedness to that larger culture
by now it's almost a commonplace to
observe that to honor Vince is almost
like honoring architecture itself which
indeed it is for he and architectures
noblest aims are virtually synonymous
but I want to say also that when we
think events we think of something else
as much as architecture and that is the
idea of the world and the newly holy
connection that Vince forged between
architecture and language the search to
find meaning in this mysterious profound
and glorious relationship that there can
be between architecture and words for
what Vince did for his entire life was
to use words spoken words and written
words both in all their great and
majestic power and beauty as a way of
helping us understand all that
architecture is and can be and can mean
I first encountered him when I was 16
years old and eager high school junior
making an exploratory visit to Yale a
friend had said that since I was
interested in architecture I should try
to look in at one of those lectures by
this architecture professor
architectural history professor who well
he didn't know quite how to care
arise him but my friend said I would not
be disappointed I was not disappointed
for four years I sat in the Law School
Auditorium alas Yale would only give me
credit for one of those years but
nevertheless I kept coming back sitting
in those creaking seats watching and
listening wallowing and words and
rhythms that I loved hearing repeated
again and again his lectures were not
unlike a favorite piece of music and
when you were 20 years old you believed
that any piece of music worth hearing
cannot be heard too many times of course
hearing scholar year-after-year wasn't
really hearing the same thing because
the lectures were never exactly the same
part of what always made Vince so
special was that every lecture was
different and reflected his thinking at
exactly the moment he delivered it it's
from those years of sitting in the
auditorium that I learned from Vince not
only about Frank Lloyd Wright not only
about Louis Kahn not only about Robert
venturi but about several things that
are much more important than any
architect Vince taught us all that
serious intellectual inquiry need not be
inconsistent with passion and that
empathy is a true and legitimate part of
analysis
he showed us that for all the joy there
is in knowledge for its own sake that
putting knowledge to active use for
social good is an even higher calling
and most important of all that the
making of architecture cannot be
separated from the making of community
indeed that the very purpose of
architecture is to make our common
ground our commonality via visible and
thereby to shape a civilization over
time Vince started his career as an
unabashedly braider of the most heroic
ambitions of modernism which he came
gradually to question one of his
greatest gifts as a teacher was his
ability to admit to both his students
and his readers that he might have been
wrong about something
that he had changed his mind ultimately
he would come to think of urbanism as
equally important to form making and to
cherish older building so much that he
became an ardent preservationist he
expressed regret as we just saw in that
clip for failing to speak out against
the demolition of McKim Pennsylvania
Station saying in what became one of his
most famous lines one entered the city
like a god now you scuttle in
underground like a rat not the least of
the pleasures of going first today is
that I can use that line without
worrying if somebody else will use it
first in 1969 Vince wrote in a much less
quoted passage that art history had to
be conservative experimental and ethical
it was a remarkable trio of words one
that in itself shows Vince's exquisite
sensitivity to language conservative
because he knew that our history had to
respect the past since learning from the
great work of history is central to its
purpose experimental because at the same
time Vince wanted to make the point that
the real value of understanding the
architecture of the past must be to
inspire the highest creativity in the
present and ethical because he believed
that the noblest mission of
architectural history at least as he
practiced it was to encourage the
building of community and the betterment
of civilization that is Vince's true
legacy his belief that words can change
the world
no Yale president could fail to
appreciate Vince's brilliance
originality and passion and the profound
life enriching impact he had on our
students that said Vince did not always
make life easy for a Yale president his
respect for the perfection of New
Haven's plan borrowed by John Davenport
from Ezekiel's vision of God's city and
his passion for the beauty and
authenticity of its buildings and parks
impelled him to hold Yale's buildings
and their placement to an exceedingly
high standard here's what he wrote at
the conclusion of the book that we
commissioned for Yale's tur Centennial
University buildings should be among the
city's most enduring it is after all
something like immortality that they D
lend offering an escape from the
restrictions to life that ignorant
imposes and a promise to lives unborn
this should be especially true of Yale
in New Haven God's City under the
mountain Haven of Exile heaven on earth
for all mankind to see Wow
this is a grand and inspiring aspiration
and in truth we work very hard to be
good stewards of the University and New
Haven but not every Yale project
proposed or executed met Vince's test
and when we failed to me to standard he
let us know a forceful argument and
characteristic passion
Vince appreciated president rizz Wald's
taste for modernist buildings he
celebrated Kahn's art gallery Rudolph's
art in architecture building Saren and
this Engels rink and Johnson's Science
Hill suite but here is his assessment of
the by Nikki library situated I use his
words situated on an empty plaza that
was sterilized for it by its architect
as perfect as a table radio and
conveying no more sense of architectural
scale little wonder that Vince went on
to torment Kingman Brewster by
encouraging Claes Oldenburg to deposit
his lipstick ascending on this very
sterile Plaza Brewster earned Vince's
high marks for cons Center for British
art but Brewers Becton Center was a
double loser a truly terrible building
built on the site of two buildings that
Brent Vince believed should never have
been torn down consider these words of
withering scorn like the by Nikki the
Becton Center was essentially a late
modern abstraction a chilling
demonstration of that design in folded
paper at which the Harvard Bauhaus
excelled
the Pilates are flatly frontal while
that densely crinkled elements of the
buildings white facade of a blinding
white facade seemed to be derived from
the grave slabs of the gross Street
Cemetery across the way the rear wall
rises up as a blank lead geometric
abstraction especially obtrusive and
hard to bear from one sickbed at the
Yale Health Services Center across the
way I had my own taste of vince's wrath
early in my presidency when we
demolished maple cottage and when we
made alterations that he regarded as
intolerable to the balcony of the
Berkeley College dining hall during our
most intense battle I came gradually to
realize that partially demolishing the
Divinity School just might not measure
up to Vince's standard of preserving
heaven on earth I surrendered these
skirmishes and other less charged
conversations with Vince were the
beginning of my education in
architecture and urban planning I was a
novice and Vince was one of those who
helped me learn to honor the built
environment of Yale and New Haven Vince
Vince smiled upon much of the work of
our later years the construction of
venturi San lien Center and especially
the meticulous and faithful restorations
of the Davies mansion and three
modernist classics Kahn's gallery the
Rudolph building an eagle's ring
Vince believed that Yale's buildings are
its greatest treasures
but anyone as privileged as I was to
meet thousands of students and alumni
knows that Yale's teachers are its
greatest treasures even more powerfully
than the buildings
Yale's teachers shape lives and give
their students that
tools to make sense of the world Vince
gave thousands of you have graduates a
gift of immense value immeasurable value
the capacity to see to feel the power of
what they see and to think critically
about what they see and feel beneath all
the fire and brimstone of this supremely
articulate critic was a deep humanity
then scared he cared about Yale his
students and the football team he cared
about buildings and streets and parks
and not for themselves alone but for the
impact they had on people and
communities his brilliance passion and
his caring touched us and inspired us
his city his university and most of all
disputes
ignoring the vituperative outbursts of
ideologues Vincent's going made the
battle for the soul of modern
architecture seem like a conversation
among reasonable people and historian a
critic and a passionate public
intellectual through his writings
Vincent Scully will continue to be
central to architectural thinking for
generations to come
I was privileged to study under Vince
more than 50 years ago his wisdom and
friendship had benefited me over the
many years since ending with my times
dean when he was sterling professor
emeritus of the history of art of
architecture as a teacher as we know and
have already heard Vince inspired
literally thousands of students Yale
undergraduates who would take away from
his classes a sense that they too had a
responsibility to help shape the
physical world and the roster of
architectural professionals who were
Scully students constitutes a veritable
who's who of contemporary practice
extending from those of my generation to
a younger generation now reaching
maturity and even those who are just
making their voices heard it is for this
reason as much as for his scholarship
his critical writing and his brilliant
insights that Philip Johnson proclaimed
him the most influential architecture
teacher ever
Scully's path-breaking first book the
shingle style 1955 not only put an
enduring name to a hitherto undefined
American tradition it also provided us
with a definitive understanding of an
appreciation for the formal and cultural
differences between European and
American architecture spawning work by
former students of my generation that he
described with pride and
a little irony as the historians revenge
though fiercely committed to the
discipline of art history
Vince was an active participant in the
life of the architecture school it was
Vince who helped sort out the myths that
lay in the wake of George house
retirement in 1954 and it was Vince who
argued on behalf of Paul Rudolph who he
believed could best return the program
to glory in my student days students
came to Yale because of Rudolph and
because of Scully in the late 1960s when
architecture students began to protest
against what they characterized
correctly in my opinion as the overblown
heroics of American modernists and
especially their participation in the
destructive slash-and-burn urban renewal
strategies that were then coming to the
fore Scully
one of the few faculty who commanded
student respect amidst the protests
embraced their cause drawing on his deep
scholarship to help shape their argument
but never abandoning his essential
belief that protests carried with it
responsibility for decorum in 1990 when
the university still held to a mandatory
retirement age of 70 Vince was forced to
give up teaching he was furious as you
can imagine I mean enlisted my help and
no doubt many others of you in this room
to make his case to the president of the
University for continuing on but it was
Thomas Beebe the Dean of the school who
saved the day by offering a teaching a
position in the graduate program which
came with a much reduced salary but that
wasn't the point for Vince he was
overjoyed to remain in the classroom by
the time I became Dean in 1998 Vince was
more than ever a principal citizen of
Yale a force measure to be respected
and as president Levin has already
alluded to on at least one notable
occasion feared one of the few who dared
to speak out about architectural issues
on Yale's campus issues of stewardship
and respect for the past when in spring
1999 with President Levin's support I
convened a symposium to assess the
university's programs for renovation and
new construction one topic came to the
fore the decision to demolish four
buildings at the Delano and Aldrich
designed Divinity School campus Scully
was the keynote speaker but after
reviewing the plans during the course of
the event that had been presented for
remodeling the Divinity School he asked
that he be allowed to return to the
platform at the end of the of the 3-day
gathering at which time before a packed
audience including numerous architects
who had been his students looking
directly at president Levin he said
quote if the Divinity School were
rebuilt according to the present plan
I'd have to rethink my future in this
institution loyalty can only be
stretched can be stretched only so far
needless to say the buildings threatened
with the wrecking ball were saved but
even more importantly Vince helped spark
a me renewed respect as president xi has
made clear for the role architecture can
and does play in a great university my
own personal debt to Vincent Scully as
that is countless of student countless
students is immense because of Vincent
Scully generations of architects and
others have chosen to pursue an
architecture and urbanism rooted in
memory rather than amnesia with a
scholars knowledge and an actor's
passion
Vincent's go he helped us to appreciate
the empathetic relationship between
humankind and
masterworks of the built environment
perhaps his greatest contribution of all
was that he taught us how to save
when I got up here
and I really you know why I'm here
because Vince didn't like me at least at
the beginning and because I breezed into
New Haven I remember what you just when
he had established a kind of master plan
for the downtown area and I arrived at
the Knights of Columbus and plopped it
in there and a couple of other things
and for several reasons he didn't like
the Knights of Columbus building but he
we sort of stayed away from each other
for a long time and then he we moved to
the jungle on the water look just on the
bay and we would go out there every
summer with our children and there was
this man who rode past every Sunday and
it turned out to be Vince and he was
drawing a very expensive and
professional boat but Lovgren alors and
after a few years we started to wave to
each other and then he would
occasionally come and play with the
children which is very nice is right
firstly so we got to be good friends but
our start was uneven because I really
didn't have any sense of arms
it just explained oh I got him in the
first place I was at school to Dublin
during the war Ireland was not involved
in the war so I graduated just as I'm
all finished and I felt I had to get off
and go somewhere and I went to London to
Mexico Friday and reward then the
leading architects and and if you went
back and decided I would come to America
question is where now when I was at
petrifies I saw a magazine which was
loading and then he thought of all very
much and I said when I've gotta study
with it and so I like I'd like to know
who I applied to Yale Harvard and IIT
where Lisa was and incredibly I was
accepted at all three and I can't
imagine why because I didn't have this
to show but I decided to go with nice
and just brief story there for about
four months he never talked to us and
then that we got a little problem to
design a house a little bit when can
Chicago on the stove was about six feet
deep and everybody decided that for
houses but I thought well it on scanned
and maybe they wouldn't do that why
didn't I catch you to pitch to the
person and so least briefly and they
said you could do that but I would not
do that you know
so I decided it was time to move on and
I did and then joined eros darling had
that wonderful ten years I saw that when
I came here I was kind all of the arrows
believers he died before he had planned
to move from do title of the world to
here and I had ended up with
responsibilities depleted to complete
six of his buildings with all these
ideas and I set aside a man on the plane
coming here and very nicely turned out
he was the mayor and when I got off the
plane I had the Knights of Columbus
building and a new school and my father
so I thought gee this is a nice place
but then I ran thought into the finish
and we didn't speak to each other or
inadvertently about each other for a
couple of years he would roll past the
water sometimes to feed the children so
we got to be good friends and he was a
very charming very articulate very
wonderful person and I agreed to do this
even though he would have preferred them
just
the innumerable things that Vin Scully
taught us I only have time to focus on
three first and foremost he taught us in
art history that none of us had heard
before his passionate searing lectures
glowed with familiar names to be sure
Giotto Michelangelo Palladio but also
Picasso Pollock Louis Kahn and Maya Lin
but he also focused of course on
well-known historical figures like
jefferson and louis xiv and his military
engineer Vauban vince had a historical
imagination and left us with a palpable
sense of history of the ages russian by
and new vistas coming to the fore but
for Vince the past was never really past
it was always intersecting with the
presence in a moving lecture he showed
how some of the boss 17th century forts
were flooded by the French during World
War two in order to slow down the
advance of Hitler's troops and I
remember the sense of bitter
disappointment when the lights went on
in the law school auditorium and we had
to balloon down to Planet Earth and
readjust to our everyday existence we
wanted to stay on on Vincent Vince's
collies magic carpet in the company of
these great men and women Brunelleschi
Titian George Washington heroic figures
like this himself larger-than-life
generous lion-hearted and this epic
yardstick which he used in his lectures
was the only one of course by which we
could use two but the only one by which
we could judge and Scully himself it is
not by chance I think that so many of
his lectures touched on the subject of
war he wrote memorably about
Michelangelo's fortification drawings
for Florence or those of Obama or of
luncheons great memorial to the dead
this dead soldiers who died at the
Battle of the Somme in World War one
it's Eva there were still battles to be
fought battles that we had to fight and
Vince wanted he fought for in art
history that came down from the sacred
groves of academia and he was deeply
deeply concerned involved engaged in the
contemporary world as an art historian
in 1989 when the Corcoran Gallery of Art
bowed to pressure and canceled an
exhibition of the work of robert
mapplethorpe Vince gave a stirring
lecture about freedom of expression
reminding us that we had to stand up
again and again he brought up civil
rights in lecture and as president Levin
and several bobster also have pointed
out went his beloved Yale threatened to
tear down a building
Vince thundered at his alma mater and
the words he used in lecture to us
students was that Yale acted like a
quote mean little Yankee institution art
history had to be militant and proactive
it had to intervene in the world around
it second thing has already run up a Bob
Stern [ __ ] taught us how to see but the
way he taught us he taught us how to see
sorry Vince taught us how to teach the
way he treated us the way he correct us
with humor so it was not so that we
would not be humiliated the way he
vented all our talks before we became
ridiculous its imposing he always
vetters he gave us time these were all
invaluable lectures for the future and
there was also his in
these warm hospitality in their home and
in every one of those dinners every time
tapi would begin a story in pause in
mid-sentence and Vince would finish the
phrase for it wasn't too many years
later when I myself was married that I
was aware of how unusual that was a
husband and wife with the same version
of the same event you are a partnership
working closely with one another and
that too was a lesson that stayed with
us
finally and here I come to bob Stern's
point Vince taught us how to see but for
Vince seeing was not something passive
it wasn't something that just happened
it required work commitment risk and
always imagination all of us who studied
with Vince have taken detours of a
hundred miles or more to see something
he had mentioned in lecture and how many
of us grad students would find ourselves
one day in the back country road in
Italy under a torrential downpour
waiting for a bus that might come in an
hour or two or a day or two you look
down your clothes or new leather shoes
were ruined mud falls boozing out but
you didn't care we had just seen a
Pilate in Villa that Vince had mentioned
and we knew that our life was enriched
amplified by this experience but Vince
could never teach us to see the way that
he did because he had an exceptional
ability to compare things that were
separated by thousands of years for
example or thousands of miles and when
he made these startling connections he
was always right and a striking example
of this has already been brought up by
professor Levin was this precisely the
peril that he brought up between the
urban plan of New Haven an exec Ian of
the ideal City nine perfect squares with
12 gates and a temple in the center
facing the sea but Vince was not it was
not about
pure formal analogy it was always
something more he was always after the
bigger picture and he adds quote it is
touching that the city Zico described is
intended as a refuge for the people who
left Jerusalem after Jerusalem was taken
and destroyed as he wrote in Yale in New
Haven architecture and urbanism the book
he co-authored with Tapie Paul
Goldberger and Eric vote New Haven is
Ezekiel's vision to the life the nine
square city by the sea the red mountain
flaring it is the New Jerusalem the most
perfect of all the Puritan towns and we
shall now hear the Society of orphism
Bacchus seeing a version of Jerusalem
that was rewritten in order to reflect
business color vision of his native city
as the New Jerusalem
[Music]
walk upon England's mountain's and was
your city
I was
[Music]
[Music]
my a gozar diesel
[Music]
my
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
president salivate tapi members of the
Skelly family please know it is for me a
very great honor to take part in this
memorial tribute a student is here to be
taught to see and to believe that
anything is possible he told me in an
interview for a piece I was writing
about him for the old architectural
forum in 1959 he was 39
I was 26 on another occasion only about
10 years ago we had met one evening for
a drink at the Yale Club in New York and
as we stepped out of the elevator of the
second floor and walked into the main
lounge he stopped to look up at at the
spectacular ceiling of that room and
exclaimed very softly almost as if he
were talking to himself
god I loved Yale he had only just gotten
off the train from New Haven but then of
course the Yale Club is another of the
master works outstanding works of James
cable gamble Rogers the genius who
created Partners Tower and so much else
all around us here less than a year ago
in the course of a conversation I asked
Vince who was your favorite teacher who
had the most influence on you he said
she was his New Haven high school
English teacher senior year miss
Sheridan
he said she rep made me read the New
York Times every Sunday
and especially the book review it was
then I came to realize as I never had
until then how much there was to read
and I began reading books books of all
kinds as never before
already by the 1950s when I was an
undergraduate his talks filled the whole
lecture hall the old lecture hall in the
art gallery every seat was taken and
many who were unregistered for the
course was stand along the side walls or
sit on the stairs leading up to the
balcony he would enter moving fast and
go immediately up to onstage
make a few quick remarks about schedules
or something of that kind in a rather
nondescript quick voice then the hall
would turn dark very dark a large image
would fill a giant screen behind him
and the show was underway the voice now
strong bourbon slightly theatrical would
unleash what one friend of his called a
musical avalanche a picture making words
never relying on a written script or
notes and stopping only only to bringing
up the heavy ten-foot long pointer on
this banging on the stage floor to
signal a change in the image on the
screen there's one story that he was got
so excited one day he fell off the stage
onto the floor and kept right on with
his lecture I certainly do believe it
often to make a point about a particular
painting or a work of architecture he
would throw in an unexpected quote from
James Joyce or scott Fitzgerald or
pilgrims progress or The Odyssey you
name it
often with marked effect though there
were times when the connection seems a
bit of a stretch many of the most of his
most impassioned lectures would be long
remembered and have far-reaching effect
for me it was those talks he delivered
on the great cathedrals of France Basel
a in particular and Jefferson's campus
at the University of Virginia and yes on
the Brooklyn Bridge but most of us who
were students here in in in my time it
was important also that he has served in
World War two as an officer in the
Marine Corps in both Europe and the
Pacific
nor did it matter that he and the other
veterans on the faculty at the time
seldom ever talked about the war if at
all they didn't have to one beautiful
spring evening back then one or two of
other of 200 students and I were coming
out of the torch Honor Society with
Vince when suddenly he stopped and
looked up at the Stirling Tower just
down College Street glowing in late
golden sunshine look at that he said
architects don't build just with steel
and stone they build with light he
helped us to see as no one ever had
helped us also importantly to understand
that history is far more than just
politics and war he showed us what he
loved again and again and with genuine
infectious enthusiasm we could never say
enough in tribute or any gratitude to
our great teachers in so many measurable
ways they are the most import
and admirable men and women of all we
can never give them enough credit or
expand or Express sufficient
appreciation above all they have
generation generation after generation
shaped our values our sense of purpose
our desire desire to excel in whether is
we chose to make of our lives and how
wonderful that for all the time Vincent
Scully spent in Greece in New Mexico and
elsewhere all the ground he covered
geographically and in his mind there was
no place he so loved as New Haven
Connecticut his home ground what an
uplifting life story he remains the
scholarship boy who became a national
treasure gone but not forgotten is the
old expression it's my view that if not
forgotten they're not gone on we go
you all know what this is I asked it to
be put up here on the stage as a as a
kind of an homage to Vincent in an
effort to garner your attention during
my short talk thank God no one turned
out the lights we all know instant in
different ways in my case he was a
mentor and an inspiration over the
course of a lifetime
whether as his student occasionally
looking at slides in the slide room in
preparation for his next lecture in my
career as an art dealer or as the owner
of the Miami Marlin baseball team i
implemented lessons he taught me every
day of my life
I wouldn't be where I am in my life
without him in the late 1950s oh that's
so long ago I started taking classes at
Yale in the art history department and
it became my major mostly because of the
indelible impression Vincent made upon
me like he has done for hundreds and
maybe thousands of others he was more
than an art and architectural giant he
was magnetic part brilliance part
showmanship when he spoke you listened
the things he taught me I couldn't have
learned anywhere else he was about
energy truth high standards wisdom
inspiration poetry and certainly made
architecture come to life
I've been around many of the world's
greatest painters and sculptors and
being in Vincent's company was no
different
in my life
visuals and interpretation are always
critical and it was Vincent who taught
me how to use my eyes to see not only
the given and the obvious how do you
measure works of art and architecture
against one another and against your own
knowledge are they good
are they great are they successful it's
all about using your eyes
I wondered then and probably still
wonder now how the hell he could see the
things he saw his eyes missed nothing in
his humanistic approach to architecture
buildings were living entities not just
slabs of concrete populating the horizon
and he taught me that we live the way we
do because of the things that surround
us we take too much for granted he often
said to me and are comfortable with the
status quo well and soon often always
said that you don't have to accept being
crippled by visual pollution I never
forgot that I remember Vincent calling
me one day to elicit my help apparently
and you've heard this before there was a
discussion about removing some of the
buildings at the Divinity School which
he felt was a crime those were his words
he felt that it still had more years to
live and had an important place on
campus he asked me to call president
Levin and lobby for his cause the
buildings were saved certainly not
because of me but rather because of his
Herculean efforts to pull out all of the
stops for something he believed in
when my daughter arrived at Yale many
years after me I suggest that you take
his course since he was nearing the end
of his career
sure enough the year after she took that
course he retired we come back as a
visiting professor and teach classes
once in a while smacking that loud point
on the floor to capture the audience's
attention have the lights go out
and the magic begin I ordered in one of
his classes many years ago along with my
wife Julie and noticed that everything
was the same except instead of
feverishly scribbling notes on paper
paper students were now feverishly
typing away on their laptops it's
beautiful that he had such a profound
influence on so many generations Vincent
was such a towering presence on campus
that even his little French Citroen
automobile which he usually parked on
Park Street behind Pearson College was
always very visible I recall one day
walking down the street with a group of
friends and football players and we all
spotted the car one suggested that we
pick it up carry it across the street
and put it on the steps of st. Thomas
More church the following Monday at his
art and architecture class Vincent came
in slammed his pointer to the ground
looked at everyone in the seat in their
seats and said who were the wise guys
who put my car on the steps of the
church
there were no responses at a Yale
football yell Harvard football game
seven or eight or nine years ago I
mentioned to Julie that I was going to
tell Vincent about that incident enough
years had passed and I thought he should
know I turned around and described it to
him and took full responsibility he gave
me a hug and said that was so marvelous
he carried no grudges he had a great
sense of humor last time I saw Vincent
was in Miami when he and Tapie were
living there
I always invited them to come to the
ballpark on opening day which was always
very festive and a wonderful experience
he loved the combination and the
commotion and the camaraderie with the
players and the uplifting atmosphere and
he would always call me afterwards to
say thank you
profusely and comment on the energy I
don't know what the energy he was
looking at but there were lots of
cheerleaders I knew that all was well in
his eyes and his heart recently I began
to think a lot about him and tremendous
emotions came roaring back in my mind I
wanted to call him and see him again
exactly twelve after hours after I had
that thought I heard that he had passed
away timing is everything
glowing obituaries came roaring in from
the New York Times The Washington Post
Associated Press and others barely
capturing the positive impact he had on
generations of architects and most
importantly young aspiring curious minds
many of them here at Yale many of those
who took his introductory course
never went on to study art history but
the exposure of two Vincent's world
I'm sure made them even more curious
about their environments I love the man
dearly
now we are left with the memory and his
writings and an indelible image of a
genius and we have opportunity here now
to honor his legacy by inspiring the
next generation to ensure that his
magical spirit continues thank you
Vince is simply the most inspiring and
influential teacher I had as an
undergraduate like so many students I
was enthralled by how Vince would take
us from the Acropolis to Monticello and
to the pueblos of New Mexico all in an
hour leaving us an absolute awe of the
power beauty and import of these great
works when I returned to jail
architecture school I was his head TA
for my near he's back at Yale I would
often stay with him in the art history
slide room and watch as he would put
that day's lecture together with his
incredible concentration as he composed
the day's talk each lecture totally
afresh with hundreds of images to be
projected side-by-side all laid out on
the light tables in the art history
slide it was a rare opportunity to see a
master at work
and to begin to understand how his
ability to thread that day's lecture
together was a brilliant composition
that visually flowed and connected as
well as being phonetically and
conceptually linked this visual
composition created an almost film white
sequence and allowed you to easily sit
through hundreds upon hundreds of images
in that darkened auditorium like
individual film stills all pieced
together
and connected with this moving booming
passionate voice and this sequencing
made it so easy for him to quite
literally transport you from the pueblos
of New Mexico to the stone monumental
structures of Mesoamerica to the Grand
Canyon and then on to the canyons of New
York City these talks would literally at
times take your breath away and leave
you in awe of the power of architecture
actually in the power of the human
spirit that would create that could
create those works for Vince inspired us
to think about the humanity within
architecture and how the built
environment influences who we are both
as an individual and as a society his
was a belief that architecture can
elevate the spirit and can inspire us to
help shape our world for the better
I for one ovince such a great debt it
was in my senior year my very last
seminar where Vince described a world
war one memorial to the missing in Kiev
all France for the Battle of the Sun
that Sir Edwin Lutyens had designed he
described it as a psychological journey
to an awareness about loss and that you
had to walk through a gaping scream of
an archway inscribed with the over
70,000 names of the missing from the
Battle of the song and as he so
powerfully and eloquently described the
experience of that memorial I realized
that a certain project of mine that I
had designed for a fall class project
for it was a memorial to the Vietnam War
had a similar psychological
it was a journey to an awareness about
loss although the two designs could not
have been more different formally while
still in that class I started madly
writing Vince was more than a little
curious but that written description of
the design was the final part that I've
been struggling with before I could send
the competition boards in and Vince's
description of the legends Memorial was
instrumental in making me understand
that my design worked on a similar
psychological level he made you feel
architecture was a living and breathing
presence for those of us fortunate to
pursue the arts and architecture his was
a voice that impressed upon us the deep
responsibility we each would have in
making our own works and for so many
others he inspired a sense of wonder
respect and lots responsibility for the
built environment he gave you a deeper
understanding of how much our built
works express our very humanity and how
much through these works we can and
should influence and shape Society Vince
urged us to think of the great social
responsibility responsibility these
works could have in his own voice in his
introduction to American architecture
and urbanism he writes there is no
difference between architecture and city
planning all must now were rather again
be treated as one this must be
especially so because of the fact that
every citizen must now share an active
and critical responsibility for the
future of the American city as for that
of the American community as a whole his
vote and his direct personal
intervention and
own community can help determine the
kind of world we will make he made us
want to help shape a better world and
the world of Salinas
good afternoon it's an honor to be with
you I speak representing my partner
under testimony who's here and many
friends in Miami where Vincent happy had
a home for some 20 years Vincent Scully
represents an era a time and modern
architecture that influenced by his
teaching and writing sought reconnection
with historic glories confronting a
building in the classroom with drama and
urgency as Michael Lewis put it one of
many recent articles about Finn's
confronting a building in the classroom
had the effect of making all
architecture contemporary Vince taught
us to value all that was good in
architecture as chewing an ideology a
gift allowing us to appreciate the world
around us with freedom unfettered by
ideology for which we are grateful and
the conviction that past and present are
one has guided generations of his
students it's important to review the
spelling era in the future it may be
seen very differently differently than
our experience of it already sometimes
it is misrepresented as cosmetic fantasy
he might exhort us all to make a record
of this time from our own experiences to
keep this record straight that others
may not see you the perspective for many
here today it is not an exaggeration to
say if not for Vince we would not be
doing what we do as students we
understood his historical benchmarks and
imagined our own work having a life
between the achievements of our
predecessors and a future that would
support continuity and we assimilated
his principles of civic responsibility
preservation and urban engagements
skully's owned such engagements ricochet
still today and still remembered
critiques of development in Miami I'm
still hearing about them and the renewed
impetus for the revival of New York's
Pennsylvania Station which is also still
an ongoing discussion many have said
that Professor Skelly changed the course
of American architecture indeed the
breadth of his audience and his
influence on the built environment
brought wide recognition much of it from
beyond his home in academia even from
the real estate development industry
consider his award from the Urban Land
Institute in 2003 the JC Nichols prize
for visionaries in urban development
what other academic can claim honors
from such a quarter from this and I the
Scully era had two phases the first has
students and young architects trying to
imagine that we were part of the
historical continuum we still remember
vividly the intellectual Awakening and
excitement of the Scully lectures from
those emerged our interest in the whole
of American architecture not just in
public buildings and monuments but in
the American house in the American
community this was the foundation for
the movement called the new urbanism and
the assessment that it was time to
recover the beauty and good sense of
American settlements it also encouraged
the traditional and classical
architecture revival that thrives across
the world today
the second phase began when Vincent tapi
joined us as colleagues at the
University of Miami they were a team he
taught his favorite courses and she
taught American architecture and
preservation they came to love the
Florida vernacular including the modest
and dignified early ranch houses one of
which they
to inhabit Finn's left our affinity with
the Caribbean and he encouraged us to
emphasize the distinct that distinction
Vincent tapi truly adopted our school
giving impetus to the faculty and
students to seek a regional identity the
success in doing so is chronicled by
them in the book between two towers and
is evident in numerous ensuing faculty
publications and buildings we remember
with happiness those special years in
Miami we are grateful to have known
Vince's creative intellect generosity
and mentoring principled passion a
mischievous sense of humor and above all
his loyal friendship and dearest happy
we look forward to your return to Miami
hi
we're shades of Yale none of us knew
professor Scully personally but we've
been told that he loved undergraduates
that he loved teaching them and learning
with them and he always set up humanly
for what he believed in and so we're so
honored to be here and to help pay
tribute to his memory this is we shall
overcome
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes someday hey sisters and brother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I just have to do this first you know
who's here
Helen chill Minh at 91 years old the
slide librarian who made everything
possible three things and I think it's
right to clap for her and for all the
projectionists and all the slide runners
and all the TFS and if you're at home
watching this you can stand up and we'll
applaud you now
so here is the scene checkerboard films
is making a film on Vince and as the
master of je and a special assistant to
the president I have been asked to go
with my dear friends Vincent a P and the
video makers and show the way to various
al buildings and opened gates with my
swipe card now it is the middle of the
day and with the video team we are at
the Yale Bowl it is this December and
the place resembles Vostok Antarctica
icicles sticking to the hard seats where
we are sitting a Tundra of grass before
us nothing like the bowl on a gorgeous
autumn day I am sitting there waiting
for Vince to say something wonderful
about this Yale place which he has known
since his childhood in which he loves so
well when suddenly he turns to tapi and
me the cameras are rolling the audio is
on and says you know Harvard Stadium is
a better place to watch a football game
shock and horror I gamely smile and nod
for the cameras while my stomach Falls
25 stories on a crashing elevator what
the dreaded Harvard the school that has
caused us so much ecstasy when we beat
them in agony whenever in the gloom of a
gathering winter evening they ground us
into the dust of our field of dreams
truthfully I had often heard Vince say
that about Harvard Stadium Harvard
Stadium is great penny because you sit
on that brutal concrete it's war like
it's death against life it's the Roman
Colosseum with the gladiators you sit
right up there on top of the action
where you can hear the cries of triumph
and anguish echo across the way but he
always said it in the context of our
perfect mutual understanding that of
course nothing nothing nothing matched
the expanse
magnificence of the bowl inspiration for
the Rose Bowl the Michigan Stadium the
Los Angeles Memorial Coliseum nothing
matched that on a gorgeous fall day and
frankly I didn't think he ever would
praise anything about the dreaded
Harvard on a film about himself and Yale
so this little episode made me think
about Richard Conniff swards about Vince
that he was the perfect inside-outside
man but actually while that phrase has a
rightness about it the truth is that
Vince was not an inside man or an
outside man or an inside outside man and
that is because he wasn't anybody's man
at all maybe tapis but nobody else's and
he was determinable irrefutably
unstoppably and unceasingly his own
person and in the black pit that covers
us from pole to pole he was the captain
of his ship he was the master of his
soul I met Vince in the 1970s when I was
teaching in Yale's English department
and Vince reached out to my late husband
the poet and translator Robert
Fitzgerald because he loved Homer and
admired Roberts translations and we
became friends but I really came to know
Vince and Tapie
in the latest 1980s when we began going
to football together I discovered the
Vincent Appius Vincent done most of his
life they were sitting in the cheap
seats far from the action as he L
somewhat improbable faculty athletic
representative I had four amazing seats
in portals 16 right behind the president
and I offered two of these to Vincent
tapi Vince theatrically snored and and
twitted me mercilessly the very idea
that he the son of a New Haven Alderman
the fiery defender of Yale radicals and
the occasional gadfly troublemaker to
Yale presidents whom he nevertheless
loved and always underlined protected
him the very idea of sitting up there
with the establishment horrified him
but allow me to convey that despite
those frightful reservations he took
disease and so for over a quarter
century he and Tapie and I through Sun
and rain through he didn't snow year in
and year out through ecstatic winds and
catastrophic losses sat in them together
even early on I always knew that going
to football as we did was not only about
the football though it was about that
football games connected Vince to his
New Haven childhood when he told me he
and his father would walk or ride out on
the trolley to the bowl and his father
would lift him up and sometimes even put
him on his shoulders so he could see the
fury of the game above the crowd it was
about driving through the New Haven
streets to get to the bowl because he
knew every street and every one of okhta
memory it was about parking on the side
of Edgewood Park and walking through
autumn leaves past the duck pond and
then up Chapel Street entering the
complex and going through the dark
tunnel and coming out out out into the
sky with the blue Yale flag flying
before us on the other side it was about
viewing the field as a palimpsest on
which he could see Alby Bluth whom he
had actually seen play and all the other
players he had known in all the other
ages moving in the shadows behind the
current players on the field it was
about that bellicose competitive thing
in him that wanted to triumph and found
its match in the game it was about the
neighborhood of these things it was
about the ritual of them the bowl and
football were to Vince
of synthesis of everything about his
childhood an age of Yale and New Haven
and of the way all this could come
together on his Saturday afternoon
although there was something in Vince's
vitality that fought the wave of death
until it literally overwhelmed him there
was also something of his knowledge of
death in his devotion to the necessary
excellence of the buildings that will
survive as monuments to what we cherish
he had such a
perfectly tuned acute awareness of death
which is as Wallace Steven said the
mother of beauty a few months before my
late husband's death years ago I sent a
New Year's poem that seemed to be about
a football game that Yale had won with a
fantastic Hail Mary pass at the end the
last lines were then throw the ball out
man
just throw the ball longer than you've
ever thrown before and waken when with
every banner waving your name announced
in every trumpet call your crowd and
teammates ferry you ashore Vince was the
only one the man with the power of
vision and acute sensitivity to language
the man with the perfect awareness of
the imperishable beauty human should
strive for who saw what my verse was
about his was the tragic sense joyful
about life despite facing the
inevitability of oblivion in which great
buildings are a stay against what he
termed nature implacable human will
unbreakable he came up to me and said
that poems not about football penny is
it that's about Robert dying the
triumphalist of the spirit as he is
being ferried ashore out of the arena in
the arms of those he loves Vince saw
that and that is what with Tapie we are
doing here we are all of us his family
and friends collectively ferrying vince
ashore in a place where his end is in
his beginning at home in New Haven and
at Yale
hello I'm Stephen the second of the
Scully's in your program I thought I
would recall a moment from our childhood
the date is 1957 we are living in Greece
for the year and at this moment we are
at marathon I'm 10 the middle of three
boys all five of us my mother and father
my brothers and I are packed in a der
cheveux the very car then mr. lorry is
just mentioned it's a tin can of a
vehicle front and back seats
I made a rubber band covered in cloth
it's got a canvas roof which can roll
down from front to back we all love this
thing it's little more than a circus car
as you've already heard as its name
implies it has two cylinders and
struggles against the wind in groans
going uphill at the moment at marathon
were on the flat just under the shoulder
of the mountain with the road such as it
is running straight to the sea a mile
away eight stage according to herodotus
where the mighty Persian army has
disembarked from its ships dad puts the
car in full throttle and we race across
the plane as fast as the car can go just
as the Athenians in full battle gear
broke into a run racing to clash with
the Persians who had landed on their
Shores dad start shouting Dallas Dallas
ah the sea the sea and we join in
roaring as loud as our lungs can it's an
exhilarating experience 60 years ago now
also more than 2,000 years
we are the ancient Athenians we're
Americans in Greece I can still feel the
rush of it the battle for freedom
Dallas is a great word to shout did this
moment that this year turn me into a
classicist probably in some way but I
couldn't say just how other things about
my father much more obviously did my
fascination my fascination with the
Greek gods dad's love my love for Greek
polytheism his persistent passion in
questioning what makes for community how
does a community conceal itself how does
it share in the divine if at all what
gives it shape cohesion how do buildings
how do individuals fit together or not
and making something greater than the
part these are things abstractly
speaking I teach that I write about I
think of them as Greek questions coming
from Greek authors like Homer he ca
Aeschylus Sophocles Euripides and Plato
but I also know deep down that they come
from you dad that they are inspired by
your own questions this is a bond that
keeps us close in some sense and in some
sense makes scholarship autobiographical
and that is probably a good thing too
this is the Greek moment I wish to share
here with you today and indulge me as I
end my remarks with words I spoke
dad's burial as the obituaries testify
many who hardly knew our father loved
him and what they loved about him was
that he enabled them to see what they
had only dimly imagined before and he
gave them soaring words to help them see
what they now saw what I want to say
here is that I loved him for the same
reasons although I would phrase them a
little differently dad taught me to look
and look and look until I finally saw
him he gave me the drive to look until I
could see he also gave me the confidence
to trust what I had seen and he gave me
the confidence to trust my imagination
in extending what I saw into an
expressive narrative these are the gifts
of a great teacher and of a great parent
for most of us 64 years of teaching at
Yale dad's office wasn't on the arched
bridge over High Street with with in
with windows looking toward sterling
library downstairs was the slide room
first and what is now the art gallery
and and in feminine street hall his
slides were always close by always
watched over by Helen Tillman twice a
week to have to walk those slides up
High Street pass Harkness tower and keep
moving toward the beloved Egyptian great
gate at the Grove Street Cemetery but
always stopped at the law school
auditorium to perform his magic with
those slides and send so many forth to
see the world anew fact is it's hard to
talk about that without his side-by-side
slides picture this on the left a High
Street bridge connecting the art gallery
with Street Hall and on the other side
at the other end of High Street the
Egyptian gate to the Grove Street
Cemetery
together these bookend the space of High
Street you could call this dad space in
December we buried dad in the Grove
Street Cemetery now he has completed the
full length of High Street from the
bridge the street to the Egyptian gate
appropriately he is now essentially on
axis with the Law School Auditorium
across the street and within the shadows
of where his high school once stood
which is mort's and Stiles now he isn't
a perfect place during World War two
while on a ship off the Sicilian coast
dad saw his first vision of a Greek
temple ruins rising above the ocean a
vision that he never felt that he
carried them all
through his life on a cemetery stone
will be a drawing by by his son John our
brother of a temple ruin posed above the
earth and between the Earth and sky
above the ocean
thank you all for Dad
besides being dad you established the
thematic axis and focus of my work much
love but how does one think tappy tappy
has made to have so much to do with his
attaining the life well-lived
297 and in the style
which he did
Yale has been the very center of Vince's
life since that first football game with
his father 93 years ago it would have
touched fence beyond telling that yellow
and memorializing in the splendid way it
has done today that these friends and
family would have spoken so fun we of
him and that all of you would have
braved the call to be here especially my
friends from Virginia
I am emboldened now to say anything at
all
because I love fence and promised him
that I would speak if any memorial
service was held for it if indeed and
because I do want to assure you that
although he has been in exile from his
beloved New Haven for the last six years
and oh how heinous this place and to
show you that although Parkinson's took
at all fenced in enjoy life bravely
until the very few weeks before his
death Vince decided to leave our dear
little house in New Haven simply because
he couldn't climb the stairs to the only
bedrooms in the house and we had my
parents home in Lynchburg with a bedroom
on the ground floor his family and many
of the friends hazarded the trick to
central Virginia he struck up near
friendship stair and one of his dearest
very dearest Lynchburg friends John
Giles died only this morning he nurtured
in Lynchburg a new passion for the Opera
he played those discs had an
ear-splitting decibel level
while he pedaled away on his exercise
bike for the metaphor part of a daily
hour and so just as once before he died
and he recognized various that his
mother had sung so well she was a
semi-professional opera singer so many
decades before of course Vince read
incessantly he read everything he wrote
a little he agonized over the present
peril in which the country finds itself
we streamed movies nightly he missed
growing so much that he took his robots
to Lynchburg just so it he could look at
them he missed teaching so much that he
made new pupils of his lung
young therapists he gave them classic
novels then discussed the books while
they exercised together
no one has mourned Vince's death more
than our husky Enzo who would not leave
from his bedside until the end
Vince did not talk much about about
death except to say how much he hated to
leave this beautiful world but more than
thirty years ago in a film he made for
New York's Metropolitan Museum he did
talk about death in relation to a
painting in the collection there before
we all gather again for a reception just
across the way a reception at the Art
Gallery I think it only fitting that we
give the last word in this service to
Vincent's himself in this clip from that
film
this painting by Durand called
thanatopsis which means roughly a view
of death best sums up all these
attitudes the title is from a poem by
William Cullen Bryant very strange poem
for a young man to write in which
attempts to reconcile mankind to dying
by pointing out that the majority of
mankind lies dead in the earth and that
when one dies one goes back as it were
home to nature and becomes part of it
and the painting is like that under the
trees as a quiet
burial ceremony up to the right
magnificent alpine masses loom and
castles of great antiquity rest upon but
then down toward the light again is in
the Oxbow goes the lovely garden out to
the transcendence of the distance and so
on is made to feel that in dying in
being put to rest in the earth there is
a great peace and the earth itself
celebrates the grandeur of the coming
and out beyond in the distance the light
of transcendence flares all of that
speaks very close to American needs
seems to me at anytime for an American
who travels to Europe all of a sudden
there's the realization that there is
another attitude toward death than ours
one in which it's more natural precisely
because the father's for sojourn so many
generations sleep there and it's this
that attempt to reconcile Americans to
death to the common fate of all mankind
it's with that that thanatopsis the poem
and the painting deal
to him who in the love of nature holds
communion with her visible forms she
speaks a various language for his gayer
hours she has a voice of gladness and a
smile and eloquence of beauty and she
glides into his darker musings with a
mild and healing sympathy that steals
away their sharpness ere he is aware
when thoughts of the last bitter hour
come like a blight over thy spirit and
sad images of the stern agony and shroud
and all and breathless darkness in the
narrow house make thee to shudder and
grow sick at heart
go forth under the open sky and list two
nature's teachings so live that when thy
summons comes to join the innumerable
caravan which moves to that mysterious
realm where each shall take his chamber
in the silent halls of death thou go not
like the quarry slave at night scourge
to his dungeon but sustained and soothed
by an unfaltering trust approach thy
grave like one who reps the drapery of
his couch about him and lies down to
pleasant dream that's what it's about
that's what Americans are trying to find
in the continent they're trying to find
that past those father's graves they'd
like to belong here it's not possession
the furniture doesn't do you that much
good in that way the silver the great
chess a glassy clothes with the bright
buttons on them in the end you own
nothing you go back but you belong to
the land you return to and there's
another kind of hope in transcendence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]